riverside county supervisor jeff hewitt
is a successful pool construction
entrepreneur turned politician won for
elected officials governing an area of
california with the population of 2.4
million and the most powerful public
official in america affiliated with the
Libertarian Party I always think about
is it hurting somebody is there
something I can do to lessen the
Inquisition of the government and have
it instead defend our rights like it's
supposed to a recent meeting of the
Board of Supervisors want a bill to
regulate the sales of home baked goods
came up for discussion he would dissent
it I remember back in the 50s and early
60s my mother would make apple pies for
laws coffee shop up in Oakland so back
then it wasn't a problem I think most of
the people around Oakland made them for
the restaurants and I don't think
anybody ever died from that my
background comes from starting my own
business when I was 19 just digging
swimming pools eventually I got to
building pools but the things I learned
about that were to get through the tough
times bring in my budget and in those
really great times you know still put
some stuff away so I could survive to
see the next day before he was elected
to his county seat in November 2018
Hewitt was mayor of the town of Calimesa
where he cut ties with the state fire
agency because it was charging too much
it's common knowledge around electeds
nobody goes against fire because that's
political suicide
so I basically was able to convince my
colleagues over there that don't worry
about getting reelected let's do the
right thing in 2018 Hewitt whose largest
donor was libertarian tomato magnate
Chris roofer spent less than half the
money campaigning then did his Union
backed establishment Republican opponent
and won anyway he says that the
Riverside County libertarian party has
seen a 42 percent spike in registration
since his victory the nice thing about
being a libertarian is we could reach
out to the Democrats on a lot of things
especially social issues that we agreed
on and we could also reach out to the
Republicans on a lot of the fiscal and
regulatory issues so it put us in a
really good place and this is what I
think a lot of libertarians don't
understand we are the great consensus
builders and peacemakers and we need to
go ahead and market that Hewitt's
district is historically Republican but
has skewed democrat in recent years
something he says he was able to
capitalize on to best his opponent one
of the biggest mistakes that
libertarians make is to think that
Democrats are harder to persuade than
the Republicans are now on social issues
criminal justice reform we're right
there with them we've already made a
connection they're a little bit tougher
is to say look you want to go ahead and
make people's lives better economically
let me show you how free market systems
have worked for me don't even need to
use the word capitalism but that cell is
a little bit easier to believe it or not
that people think on our board we have
two Democrats and two Republicans I'm a
libertarian it allows me to not only
build a consensus but when there's very
contentious issues I can be that swing
vote too so being a libertarian is the
most important thing to me and it's Who
I am
into aspiring Libertarian Party
politicians Hewitt's advice is to pick
winnable races and focus more attention
on the basics like public speaking and
social skills take Toastmasters and get
to know how to speak in public and also
make friends like me get appointed to a
Planning Commission you make friends
their relationships you start building
trust in the community and now people
don't care if you're a libertarian or
whatever you are you're gonna be someone
that they're gonna have an easier time
voting for
but despite his electoral success Hewitt
still faces considerable opposition from
his fellow board members on several core
issues he dissented from an agreement
the board reached with the Service
Employees Union that he believed would
ultimately bankrupt the county others on
the board including conservative
Republicans voted for the agreement I
sincerely respect the issues being
raised by my colleague supervisor Hewitt
he's right on the money we have to start
somewhere
and I just don't think that it starts
with our going after our employees I
think it starts up here at the Dyess
going after the bigger picture issues
that we face today but Hewitt believes
that if he sticks with his principles
he'll inspire other libertarians to join
him in the fight pick a race that you
can win a lot of these local races
they're actually still very powerful but
they don't cost a lot of money when two
to four years maybe 10 years all of a
sudden you're in a very very impactful
position you can really make a lot of
big changes then it won't be so lonely
for me
[Music]